China has infiltrated Cuba and is using
it to spy on Americans right now as we
speak on June 8th 2023 The Wall Street
Journal dropped a bombshell China had
just agreed to pay Cuba billions of
dollars to open up a secret new spy base
on the island new reports suggest China
is in talks with Cuba to establish a spy
base on the island nation and just 100
miles south of the U.S in the news
shocked the US government to its core a
Chinese spy base just 100 miles off the
coast of Florida would change the
balance of power between America and
China forever the biggest threat of
China spying on Americans wouldn't come
from Tick Tock anymore it would come
from a state-of-the-art electronic
surveillance base that could do way more
than just track Tick Tock users and if
we ever went to war with China China
could store nuclear weapons missiles and
soldiers there just an arms length from
American soil over the decades America
has done everything in its power to
surround China with military bases and
allies but now it seems like the tide is
turning China has already infiltrated
Latin America which we covered in a
recent video and now they have a
full-blown spy base right off the coast
of Florida according to Mike Waltz a
member of the House intelligence and
armed services committee if China
building a spy Base in Cuba wasn't
enough evidence that we're in a new Cold
War I don't know what is yes this is a
new Cold War and China's infiltration of
Cuba could lead to the next Cuban
Missile Crisis
[Music]
foreign
guys if you're like me and you prefer
having a super simple minimalist
wardrobe so you don't have to stress
about what to wear then you gotta check
out true classic I don't need to tell
you how hard it is to find a good
t-shirt oftentimes they're expensive
don't fit well the fabric doesn't feel
high quality but with true classic their
best-selling t-shirts are super
affordable while having a super clean
simple fit while also being really
comfortable the chest fits well the
sleeves aren't too big or too small the
back of the neck hole is flush for your
skin so you can be comfortable while
looking your best I got a pack of their
white t-shirts and another pack of their
black ones but it's not just t-shirts
true classic is your One Stop Shop for
your entire wardrobe including joggers
outerwear and every kind of shirt type
you could want and for a limited time
you can upgrade your wardrobe with 25
off using the code Jake with the link
below that's 25 off with code Jake by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to True classic for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
China and Cuba have a lot in common both
countries are ruled by communist parties
both have been sanctioned by the West
both have had a pretty difficult
relationship with America and both were
in the position to be very useful to
each other after years of strict
American sanctions Cuba relies a lot on
China for investment in loans and China
has always liked having an ally so close
to American soil so it makes sense that
China will want to have a listening post
there at just 100 miles off the coast of
Florida a multi-billion dollar Chinese
spybase would have a lot of reach the
way that I see the danger in this is
something called eelins or electronic
communications by having some kind of a
listening post is what we call them
Central Command is in Tampa Florida and
then Fort Bragg is in North Carolina and
they would potentially be able to
collect on those bases now certainly
those bases have mitigation in place to
stop that kind of collection but really
that's what would be in the zone America
may have measures in place to protect
against foreign surveillance but no
protection is foolproof take the
Pentagon for example the biggest
intelligence lease since Edward Snowden
this happened because a 21 year old kid
in a position no better than a janitor
somehow had access to Top Secret
documents so if a 21 year old kid can
get access to these top secret documents
imagine what well-trained Chinese spies
could get their hands on with
state-of-the-art technology just a few
miles off the coast if this base was
built some of America's most important
Navy military training and command
centers will be in perfect range to be
spied on even worse every single
American ship that passes through the
Gulf of Mexico North Atlantic and
Caribbean Sea will become a Target not
to mention the millions of regular
Americans and military personnel who
could potentially have their phones
tapped and their Electronics hat it
would be an intelligence nightmare if
this base was built Chinese and American
spies would have to fight each other on
equal footing for the first time in
history and what's crazy is that this
giant development caught the government
by surprise they didn't even see it
coming but if the American government
admitted that this deal happened right
underneath their noses and they had no
way to stop it it would be like
admitting that we are powerless to
China's slow encroachment on America's
borders so the American government did
the only thing they could think of they
denied everything
[Music]
foreign
hours of the report dropping everyone
involved said it was fake news Cuban
officials called the rumor totally
untrue and slander they said it was just
another story America made up as an
excuse for sanctioning Cuba China was a
little bit more creative saying that the
United States should reflect on itself
and stop interviewing in Cuba's Internal
Affairs under the banner of Freedom
democracy and human rights according to
China the best way to stop China from
spying on America was for American ships
and planes to stay away from Chinese
territory watch out for your own
territorial Waters and airspace then
there will not be any problems but China
and Cuba denying this isn't exactly
surprising it's supposed to be a secret
spy base after all but what no one
expected was for the American government
to come out and deny the report too I've
seen that press report it's not accurate
what I can tell you is that we we have
been concerned since day one of this
Administration about China's influence
activities around the world certainly in
this Hemisphere and in this region we're
watching this very very closely and we
will and we have and we'll continue to
take steps to mitigate any Potential
Threat that those activities might pose
so that we can make sure and we are
we're positive that we can continue to
defend this nation but the problem
this report was leaked by American
officials in the first place so why
would the American government want to
denied us why would they want to
contradict their own employees and tell
everyone that there's nothing to worry
about wouldn't it be better if everyone
knew about this so they could
fear-monger us into paying more taxes
for the military industrial complex why
was America trying to cover this up Cuba
and China's denial made complete sense
but there was no reason for America to
want to cover this up unless the
government was trying to cover up
something bigger something that they
have been hiding from the American
public for more than four years
something that they told everyone not to
worry about and then just two days after
the first report dropped the truth
finally came out
yeah
it turns out the American government was
telling the truth when it called the
report on China's Cuban spybase
inaccurates but not for the reasons you
think see China was never planning on
paying Cuba billions of dollars to build
his first ever spy based on the island
no because I already had a spy based on
Cuba as early as 2019. that's right that
was the big secret the US government
wanted to cover up for at least four
years China has been able to Monitor and
collect electronic data on millions of
Americans from Cuba without any of us
knowing about it according to a high up
official President Biden had told this
government to deal with it quietly and
carefully so quietly that many
government employees and politicians
knew nothing about it and according to
them their counterintelligence strategy
have been working until now because as
it turns out all that progress they
thought they were making was probably
just China and Cuba messing with them so
in less than 48 hours officials from the
Biden administration had contradicted
themselves multiple times about whether
or not the CCP is spying on the US this
is unacceptable said one representative
and he's not wrong the two reports the
administration put out definitely
something like that contradicted each
other but what if they were both true
it's likely that America have been
trying to close down China's existing
spy capabilities in Cuba for years now
and maybe China and Cuba played along at
first tricking Americans into thinking
that they were making progress while in
the background it was a different story
in the 1960s the Soviet Union opened up
the biggest foreign spy base ever to
exist in the Western Hemisphere just
outside of Havana Cuba and this Soviet
base inside of Cuba resulted in some of
the most terrifying tense years in
American history culminating in the
Cuban Missile Crisis when America and
the Soviets came closer than ever to
firing off new glue missiles and now the
CCP is using the exact same Playbook
with Cuba we've said it on the channel
before and we'll say it again we are in
a new Cold War make no mistake about it
and this time with Kiba already under
heavy American sanctions the US
government might not have any leverage
to use against Cuba to get them to kick
the CCP outs and with our Southern
border wide open regardless of your
opinion on that it's safe to assume that
China already has many spies on American
soil I mean if you were them why
wouldn't you and what will these spies
be used for well when the time comes the
easiest most unguarded Target for them
to attack that will cause the most death
and Mayhem will be our electricity grid
because shockingly all it takes is just
nine key substations to be knocked out
and the entire us would lose electricity
for 18 months or more it will result in
millions of deaths and these substations
are barely even guarded but we'll save
that for an upcoming video so stay
dangerous and subscribe
[Music]